We have a very interesting voicemail today.
It's about Michael Bloomberg.
And this is actually something that people
have been emailing me about as well.
Our friend Ben Dickson, unearth a horrible,
horrible audio of Michael Bloomberg talking
about black people and stop and frisk and
it's, it's really, really bad to someone with
more progressive sensibilities, but this color
and some people who have been emailing are
arguing that this might actually be good for
Michael Bloomberg in some parts of the country.
Let's take a listen.
Yeah, just a few words here on the Bloomberg
polling data that you recently talked about.
Sadly, I actually think that audio recording
helps Bloomberg's campaign from industry,
uh, not only in the spotlight mine, which
is Texas with a lot of what the growing up
moderate, uh, population of Democrats.
But, uh, throughout the lower Mason-Dixon,
uh, my worry is that Bloomberg picks up center
left voters as well as people in the right
who see, uh, Bloomberg as, uh, half the height
and double the Derby skills of Trump.
Okay.
Uh, my question to you is, does this, does
this concern you and should Bernie's campaign
be more proactive in getting, uh, uh, in front
of all of this before it, uh, it gets out
of hand before that there's a larger narrative,
uh, that they draft from this.
Yeah.
So the, the risk for Bernie of starting to
go after Michael Bloomberg right now is that
as of yet, Michael Bloomberg has gotten zero
in every primary because he's just ignored
the first four primaries.
And if you're Bernie strategists, I don't
know that you feel it's a good idea to start
going after someone who hasn't been in a single
debate and who hasn't received a single vote
yet.
At the same time, there's no question PO,
uh, the, the polling suggest Bloomberg is
going to do okay on super Tuesday.
I don't know that I agree that the racist
stadio will be good for Bloomberg in the primary
because there there's no question and we got
some calls on our Tuesday night stream.
There are voters who just don't care about
the racist Bloomberg audio.
They have sort of, he's better than Trump
and he actually is a good businessperson and
I'd vote for him sort of mentality.
People who don't care about the racist audio.
I don't know that there are too many democratic
primary voters who are going to say, Oh, racist
audio.
I'm going to go and vote for Michael Bloomberg.
Especially because it seems to me that a lot
of those more racist, uh, of voters, number
one may not be voting in the democratic primary
at all.
And number two, they may also be antisemitic
and they, they may not vote for Michael Bloomberg
because he's Jewish.
So I don't know that I, I buy that, but I
do think there is a very good chance that
the racist audio doesn't do a significant
damage to Michael Bloomberg.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about who benefits the most from
Andrew Yang dropping out of the presidential
race.
We're going to talk about a Utah bill decriminalizing
polygamy, which has actually cleared its first
hurdle.
And we will also talk about more disgusting
revelations related to Congressman Jim Jordan.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show,
get access instantly by becoming a member@goingpacmandotcomorbecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].